[Music]
Kyrgyzstan more than 90% of the country
is mountainous with peaks up to seven
and a half thousand meters high
most Kyrgyz people live from farming or
animal husbandry the climate is harsh
and the cuisine is rustic
baking is often done in a clay oven for
example to produce the traditional
flatbread of the region called lopaka
it's a simple snack but an attractive
one
flour sugar butter salt and yeast make
up the dough and off it goes into the
oven after baking for 15 minutes the lip
yoshi are done they self around 35 cents
apiece
thirteen-year-old rosa hoon delivers
them to the market every morning marmor
has been making them for 10 years in
this family-owned bakery he bakes 500
l'apicio's a day it's a good business
[Music]
hadn't done I said okay and Thursday at
the knowledge non-target alone people
always are bred for occasions like
funerals or weddings toil are eager may
get what I'm really endeavors the excel
level others it's a popular brand and
it's a staple for us super annoying each
other although the bakery is a bit out
of the way the customers always stop by
to pick up their lip Yoshika fresh from
the oven
the flatbread is served at nearly every
meal in kyrgyzstan the regulars come in
the morning to stock up for the day uh
no ocean of course never get it tastes
good
it's warm and it's pleasant to eat I
always buy the bread here because it's
always fresh bit that neither the bakers
intend to pass on the bread recipe to
the next generation they're certain that
lip Yoshio will retain its popularity in
kyrgyzstan for years to come
you